why don't we go next to Thomas from New
York Thomas from New York welcome to the
David packman show
hey David how's it going well
all right so um I'm sure you know
obviously that Donald Trump got indicted
last week and that may or may not affect
Trump's run for president but yes um I
may just want to ask about Ron DeSantis
some people say that Ron DeSantis is
more of a threat to democracy than
Donald Trump is through the multiple
bills he assigned in Florida so just
don't say gay bill and his bills are uh
to affect elections my question is is if
you agree with the sentiment that Ron
DeSantis is more dangerous to the
sanctity of democracy if he would become
president rather than Donald Trump Post
January 6 and his arrest
I generally believe so this this is the
way I kind of frame it if you said to me
today
either Trump or DeSantis will be
president for four years I think I see
DeSantis as the greater threat and would
say if those are my choices I would
rather Trump be president four years
rather than DeSantis DeSantis seems much
more focused whereas Trump's brain is
kind of all over the place DeSantis is
likely to be more effective at actually
making horrible
legislative accomplishments whereas
again Trump gets so distracted and
embroiled in controversy that I think he
would be less effective the Counterpoint
to all of this is that on the world
stage Trump is so cartoonish and such a
joke that it might damage American
reputation more to see Trump president
for another four years than DeSantis so
it's sort of like DeSantis would make
our reputation not quite as bad but he
would do far more damage now there's
another layer to this which you didn't
directly ask about but I think is also
important
in the polling right now there's Trump
versus Biden polling and DeSantis versus
Biden polling Biden does better against
Trump than against DeSantis so that
would be another reason to want Trump as
the nominee rather than DeSantis because
it seems it's more likely to lead to a
Democratic president winning in 2024 but
again this is all very early polling
data
yeah I think Trump is definitely is a
lot more cares about his ego so he will
be less he kind of doesn't get LED as
much by the Republicans I think Ron
DeSantis is a lot smarter and a lot more
nefarious in that way I think that's
true I appreciate the the answer my
pleasure Thomas from New York uh great
to hear from you uh got right to his
question I mean really a perfect phone
call Audio was good just a good call in
really every way